can't let's talk about them live shows
baby that middle-class famous tour
that's a good good time that
middle-class famous tour we're coming to
a city near you it's a stand-up comedy
show then we play a little ayg with the
crowd fantastic way to introduce new
people to the show grab your best guy
grab your best gal grab your girlfriends
grab your guy friends bring the whole
squad and come see us yeah gang next
week uh september 13th we're going to be
in kansas city then september 14th we're
going to be in springfield all right
then in september 15th we're going to be
in st louis then in october coming to
nashville we're going to indy november
we're going to philly's second show out
of there that's almost sold out get
those tickets don't sleep on that then
we're coming to providence rhode island
and boston in december those shows are
sold out at the moment but we're adding
tickets be on the lookout yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage they do little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're good to be
classy after just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here in auntie's basement she's upstairs
making a nice big breakfast okay four
o'clock in the afternoon my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me
unamused this week big strikeout that
one i mean we did a second take for that
he's the ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman he's not to be
trifled with in the board room or the
bedroom give it up for kj kevin james
ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true
almost at 100 000 over there let's go uh
and then obviously the greatest website
of all time www.patreon.com
are you garbage check it the [ __ ] out
gang sweet lord and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he wrote that hoodie this
week didn't want me to tell you give it
up for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
what's up dudes no i [ __ ] didn't
you know
great distance between anybody in that
joke i started sweating that stuck so
bad
but that's neither here nor there god
damn it we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he is a very funny stand-up
comedian podcaster just one of the
truest stand-up comedians working a true
headliner yours it gets a [ __ ]
murderer you can hear him every week on
we might be drunk with mr mark norman
who they both also have bodega cat
straight rye whiskey machi going old
school i like it couple of bootleggers
they're not doing flavored vodka and
they're like that they're going straight
ride wouldn't that be great if we did if
we're like
it's like skinny lemon margaritas it's
like cream vodka everybody loves that
that is so beautiful i'll tell you i
have gotten drunk on whipped cream vodka
you throw a little orange juice in that
oh yeah [ __ ] creamy baby dude when
pinnacle hit i was we were all about
medical good night cotton candy wow we
were getting wacky with it we came out
of the gate garbage
you know what's pretty good
gang he also has a new podcast with her
julian edelman called games with names
that you gotta check out but the reason
that he's here
what's the reason that he's here
he's got a little special over there on
a netflix i'm not talking about one of
them freebies they give away we're
talking about netflix baby we're talking
front page netflix i looked at it today
it's called same time tomorrow ladies
and gentlemen mr samurai look at that oh
my god that was look at that that was
that was incredible that role you just
got out thank you
yeah no i'm pumped i'm pumped getting
nice feet i went uh viral on trans
twitter i'll take it there you go trans
twitter's loving me right now it'll
it'll turn i know you look familiar
i'll take it for now
buddy congrats man it's [ __ ] awesome
it's great yeah it's fantastic we love
this like as you said as pure of a new
york stand up you can be yeah i meant
one of the best joke writers thank you
in the country
i'm so pumped that this podcast is blown
up thank you buddy oh thank you thank
you i love to watch you sit back [ __ ]
you hang back and you just [ __ ]
murder it looks effortless
uh it's a lot of work i know
and the special is [ __ ] fantastic and
like we said it's [ __ ] tearing up the
charts over there i guess they don't
tell you it's like serious where they're
like they're like are you doing it is it
good i don't know did anybody see it
they don't release numbers but i'm like
i feel like yeah i'm getting nice
feedback i think when it gets the front
page and trending and stuff like that
you know it's doing some numbies i was
flying from texas to burlington vermont
not good routing obviously for a giver
uh you know weekend in vermont and it's
like that it's you know when you're on
the runway and you're like i'm not gonna
make the connection i'm connecting in
your home philly i'm you know i'm like
two hour delay the the flight
attendant's like i think you're gonna
make it i don't think i'm gonna make it
but she's really building me up she's
like i think they're gonna hold the
plane i was like they don't they don't
hold planes that's not a thing they do
for one dude anyway then i got morel
coming up
throw the brakes on dude i get i land
and she just goes run i think he can
make it so i'm running and it's like we
land in b2 and i'm like please be close
[ __ ] f-32
i'm dead i don't understand why they do
that man it's crazy it kills me so i'm
sprinting they close the door right as
i'm getting i'm like please don't close
it she goes sorry close it what the [ __ ]
and she goes i can't open it it's closed
i'm like but you [ __ ] you closed it
that's a real [ __ ] it killed me so
then i had to go from uh there's a day
it came out and i go what the [ __ ] as
i'm doing oh what the [ __ ]
phones are coming up and i'm like i'm
gonna go viral the day my special comes
out for not my special yeah
i'm going what the [ __ ] why would you do
that and uh i know i'm gonna miss the
gig that night so i'm just furious and
then she goes i can get you on a flight
to chicago so i'm going back to chicago
to burlington so that's and i was like
what do i do and she goes uh you got
they're bored in seven like it's
boarding now you got seven minutes to
get there i said where is it i [ __ ] you
not b4
i'm [ __ ] that's all right i sprinted i
made it it took me nine minutes to get
here
dude i hate a long airport i i know i'm
a fat pig i hate a long airport
i hate when i see multiple of those flat
escalators i know i'm in trouble oh dude
you see a cinnabon like down in the
distance you can barely make out the
sign that shits well
people look up you're zipping around
people and they're looking up from their
phone and you we've all seen that person
you're like that person's not making
their flight yeah they're never making
it they're about to learn the wrong
terminal they should be a laguardia
probably let me ask you this uh do a
little recap do a little a little check
up on you here uh these flights you
flying you're flying up front what's
going on in japan you gotta be you know
some of these flights now dude
i'll tell you i just spent fifteen
hundred dollars on a main cabin round
trip ticket to louisville whoa it's
never the place you want to go you lose
a bet what the [ __ ] hey zone two take it
easy
jesus i'm like what the hell i'm like a
flight to paris is probably 800. yeah
louisville is 1500 now what the hell uh
so that it's nuts yeah if it's if it's
not insane i'll sometimes i'll go up
front but yeah i mean what i mean also
you have the
you fly every week you get the status
but sure i think east coast to west
coast sometimes i will but i mean dude
every once in a while you're like and
also if i'm going to like burlington
normally that's what a two hour an hour
flight you're like what am i i'm gonna
pay an extra 200 for like this much
extra yeah but that's when you get to
cheap that's when you get the cheap
upgrade you look cool on the plane
45-minute flight cup 1500 bucks or
something like that
i'm so bad with money i use it in both
ways i'm like well flying cross-country
i got to spend the extra 1500 bucks and
i go i'm flying to vermont it's 40
minutes it's a couple bucks whatever
you get like a slightly better kind bar
that's it that's all i got in first
class
multi-grain cheeses
i was telling him dude
we flew to south carolina me and my girl
just for just just to chill out for a
couple days we're in south carolina we
went to charleston oh that's beautiful
dad it was awesome i was like if you
said myrtle beach i was gonna go garbage
spring break baby yeah we just went
topless we got tattoos arrested and
she's pregnant um no i went to
charleston but we were on a jetblue
flight and there was no first class and
that made me nervous
i don't like it i feel like those can
crash
easier and nobody would really care
because you feel like no one important
yeah there's nobody important give me a
cfo or something or like you know some
athlete trying to make the team and
they're right when people die on fl kobe
died in the helicopter
important people do die yeah john denver
right i mean there's he was flying
himself though that's true he was
looking forward i was gonna i was gonna
mention another yankee who also flew
himself who [ __ ] no god damn the
catcher thurman munson oh yeah
same with uh roy holiday right he was
flying yeah dude that was he was crazy
that jet was wild he was flying too yeah
yeah yeah that guy that was like one of
the best pitchers ever that was insane
awesome you never get into that stuff
later in life you like dirt bikes you
got to do that when you're a kid you
don't pick those things up the flying
the helicopters and stuff like that get
out of here have you ever been in those
tiny like helicopters ever they're
they're terrifying i can't fit yeah no
we tried so what the fact that we're
making like i know the little ones
you're talking about and if i was four
pounds i still wouldn't get in that
[ __ ] thing dude so for like a stunt i
was like you know what we were doing a
show on failures last year i was like
let's get a [ __ ]
let's get a helicopter and fly down
there in the sense of like we're going
to spend all the money we're making just
to get there and then we're going to
take the bus back as like a bit and uh
so i start calling around i'm like i
need a helicopter from new york to
philly like no problem they're like how
many people you got like i'm like what's
the and they go how big are the nobody
over 300 pounds like ah that's going to
be a problem i probably got a hold of
one guys yeah we'll do it i'm like i
don't want to fly with you wow seven
people said no and some guy's like yeah
who gives a [ __ ] i'm like all right wild
bill's chopper service i'll get that fat
bastard down there yeah we'll do it
airlines that's not where you it's not
what you want to be on we'll do it
damn that is so you so you wouldn't get
on
i wouldn't i know i was at that point
like seven people had told me no and i
was like let me just try this one i
can't believe you made it to seven after
like three said no to me i'd be like no
we're not
hey we love the fans we want to get the
content out there
it is a good the coast guard is going to
have to take them down
they're gonna have to drown them in the
hudson they were gonna save them and
take them to penn
um
are you are you a lounge guy at the
airport would you do the americans yeah
no i do the delta you're delta but
that's
if you don't mind what kind of status
you could you fly diamond i'm diamond
whoa really you're dying so you have an
american express card with with sky
miles yeah yeah and you're diamond yeah
holy [ __ ] it's just some flying i'm
trying to get the wood
where are you rotty danger i love that
lounge dude that lounge the delta lounge
isn't good there's something about
getting either in the air or lounge
drunk there's something kind of
an airport it's lawless i just start
drinking but the problem is like then
you start to look at your road schedule
and you're like i'm on the road i can't
just do this regularly because i'm gone
every that's when when your friends come
out to see you at first and they're like
let's get [ __ ] up and you have that
different center group yeah coming out
of course no this is every night i can't
just get [ __ ] up or i'm gonna be in
rehab yeah that's gonna it's gonna end
horribly so you do have to kind of
budget but every once in a while like i
had that bad airport day on thursday and
i was like i'm getting [ __ ] up on the
flight oh yeah i landed late in vermont
the shows were canceled oh that's a
gimme it was a gif so but i was kind of
relieved that we moved to sunday and
then uh gary veeder and i just hit we
just got [ __ ] hammered at a uh like a
nice restaurant it was great oh that's a
good time it was a good time yeah ain't
nothing better than it
uh will you take your shoes off when you
fly absolutely not no oh
you know what actually that's not true
the one condition if you do get the
upgrade and you get those lay flat ones
that you got though i i'm six three i
gotta do it i start doing laundry
are you kidding me dude we got that once
i was like game changer it's crazy i
could have done another lap let's
[ __ ] go
i was sitting behind molly shannon on
one of those ones and i love molly
shannon
it took all my strength not to be like i
love you molly shannon
i nearly root i did that once too can
you name my shoe
please i did it once to uh you know that
actress catherine keener of course love
her love her she's
never not great you know like capote
dude everyone john malkovich and and
started out in the indies killed it in
the indians your friends and neighbors
cool movies but yeah i opened the door
out of the bathroom on a flight and
she's standing there and i just went i
love you and she went ah i was like
sorry
and then she goes thank you
thank you but that's a horrible way to
open the door
i just panicked i saw her i was like oh
she doesn't get out too i just remember
she's in so many good movies
that's funny well you bring food on the
plane
uh from like from the lounge or from
like like anyway if you stop wait oh
back it up a second wait a minute wait a
minute he's for sure stealing you're
taken from the lounge i think little
things sometimes it's it's meant for it
they have like the travel but like the
bars oh sure all right yeah but you're
not taking like a [ __ ] egg ball out
of there
i'll take them literally if it's
breakfast i'll throw a couple
hard-boiled eggs in a little thing and
i'll take them on the flight ooh that
was my hard boiled egg that's on the
list have you ever eaten a hard-boiled
egg in public
ew really dude in public they're at the
bar what do you mean
they're meant to be what am i supposed
to go in the bathroom with the egg
that's creepier see kathleen keener i
love you
getting salt
the hard-boiled egg in in public is a
tough look it's a bad luck ugh it is
look i'm not going to act like it's a
classy move but i i i like a hard-boiled
egg you know it's a little saltine
or in public that's a very new york yeah
that in a seltzer called a day and an
egg cream i remember i saw tim dillon
once saw me leave a podcast with a
protein bar he goes ugh you're such a
new yorker with your protein bar
it's like such an eye i was like i
didn't realize it's like an on-the-go
thing but you just
you know
yeah that's good
but you won't bring like a sandwich on
there i've done it yeah i'll i'll give
you a garbage one i brought a tuna sub
on it
[Music]
i've definitely done the seaweed snacks
too which is as low as it gets because
you're that dude just sucking them in
and they're just like they smell
bad and that's a gross thing it smells
like low tide yeah they smell real
tuna's a tough look though tuna is a bad
luck
on a plane is crazy
i won't do it again i really there's a
reason they don't serve tuna fish
sandwiches on the plane i swear to god
the first thing i thought i liked a tuna
hooky though i respect that i love it it
was jersey mike's it was the lax
and i i remember eating it and
everyone's looking at me at first i was
like they're jealous that i
haven't talked about being disconnected
they're jealous that i remembered a
sandwich and they didn't and then it hit
me i'm like oh it smells horrible it's
like a tuna is like a cigar of the food
world
it's great for you it's bad for everyone
else yeah
oh [ __ ] you're ruining a couple of days
god damn
that's funny dude are you still in the
same place are you still living in the
same place you were when uh when we saw
you last i am yeah very nice
okay let me say you're making dinner at
the house never maybe never i'm i'm i'm
never home i i rarely have groceries
also new yorkers don't make that you
know theoretically my fridge my fridge
looks so sad is it it's i mean it's like
all on the gosha it's like canned iced
coffee deviled eggs
it's just a tray of devil i wish shout
out to the double egg uh yeah like a few
protein shakes seltzer it's like all
like i'm leaving with this [ __ ] sure on
the go again yeah yeah but let's say
hypothetically let's say okay so for
some reason you and gary are at the
house all right you and gary are at the
house yeah you're making dinner all
right um you're gonna make pasta i love
making pasta you'll see like making
pasta during the pandemic when we did
this the first time i was cooking a ton
okay because we all were right sure you
had to so if you make pasta yeah are you
using one whole box of pasta and one jar
of sauce or are you splitting that up
are you putting the jars sauce back in
the fridge and not using it all
completely i used all the sauce i think
thank you i'm a bit i like sauce i don't
i mean it depends what kind of pasta i'm
making if it's like a red sauce i'm
using all the sauce nice for sure all
right i love all right i love a good i
mean [ __ ] man it's on netflix what do
you mean it's class right there what
about uh god what's it called the rayo's
marinara that's some of the best jar
sauce is the best best jar sauce yeah
best you can get for sure that's a good
that's a great it's worth the money i
feel like they blew up in the pandemic
too they're big they really a couple of
stores you could get them in now they
have like half the yeah
oh dude when you were in that grocery
store and people were fighting for those
last jars you're like [ __ ] i'm left with
like zesty garlic or something i want
that sensitive marinara dude we're
regular
when you're like good luck with your
ragu alfredo
oh you know i love i love all k i'll do
any kind of pasta though i mean i'll do
like a [ __ ] white wine sauce a little
pesto i'll do any of that [ __ ] all right
pesto pasta
i love getting
wine drunk with italian food that it's
hard to top that it's just so hardy
especially in the winter if you if it's
a cold new york winter and you just duck
into like a little tiny there was a
great place called via del apache that
closed down in the east village i used
to do comedy in their basement i know
exactly what you're talking about and it
was inexpensive yeah and it was great
and i'd see like i remember danilo
galinari from the knicks would eat there
all the time so that it scored extra
points when he played it and then uh
i would just it'd be like a 14 pasta for
new york that's [ __ ] amazing mm-hmm
and you eat well cheap red wine yeah
john's on 12th street it's good for that
that's a great stuck in there and a cold
night
had a bartender wouldn't say to me once
he goes my dad used to say like there's
nothing better than the moment you hit
your [ __ ] face you open new york like
the bar door in the cold winter and the
wind just hits your face i love it that
is kind of epic it's something because
that was good starts fighting the cold a
little bit it's great man the same
bartender like we talked for a while and
he's like what are you doing i avoid
saying comic but he he pulled it out of
me and he goes man i know this hilarious
guy uh i used to watch me take a real
big name i was like oh whoo he goes uh
mark normand
oh shout out to him so i was like i
literally do a podcast for that guy and
he was like he was like you know mark
norman
no he owes me 20
[Laughter]
ah shout out to mark i so badly want to
just show up with mark next time i got
you guys that was mine you know it was
corner bistro in uh in the east village
oh yeah yeah
he made it popular that place yeah but
it's a great burger spot great great
beer spot when you're counting on your
fingers do you start on your thumb or
your pinky
um you do yeah pinky who starts with
their paint
one two three four five that's weird
that's real weird yeah it's commie [ __ ]
dude
that's home school [ __ ] what are you
talking about starting with your pinky
yeah all right maybe he's like what are
you a realtor in panama what the hell
the hell is that start with your pinky
it's easier to do bumps and coke with
long nails
yeah that's wild okay uh have you ever
subscribed to maxum magazine
no no but uh you know i i've back in the
day dabbled yeah but the pre-internet
porn days these kids don't know how
lucky they have i think they have no
idea jerking at the fhm maxim whatever
we could find yeah
um
well you have magazines in the bathroom
at the house though
i don't really occasionally like i'll
i'll get magazines at the airport
sometimes okay yeah you read the
newspaper at
all paper no not really on my phone or
computer okay
but i i i do like
i do like a newspaper i like a magazine
you strike me as a guy though you can
subscribe to the new yorker at any point
in your life yeah i love you it's a
great
new york magazine also i like i like uh
i like the post i just like like the
post is a coaster all right
you just love new york i love new york
i love the subway
and then there's some i'll buy that i
just buy to like as like i'm dumb so i
should buy this and then like i'm like
i'm like i just bought the economist i'm
like i read like half an article don't
even understand anything yeah yeah oh
what am i doing popular mechanics
let's talk about the good people over
there and better help are you mean to
people out there saving a goddamn world
yes they 100 are let me talk to you guys
about something i've had issues in my
life where i get stuck in what's
happening to me rather than trying to
figure out what the solution might be
you don't say and i think to myself if i
had a better mindset about that if i had
better help
somebody that i could reach out to and
talk to and they could help give me the
tools to solve the problem how much
easier would that make accomplishing my
goals which i am just learning yes
uh talk therapy has helped me a lot in
the past and i i just decided this week
we're a couple of screw balls over here
i'm signing up for better help baby i'm
doing it this week i can't wait to get
back in the the therapy pool and figure
it out i got i'm dealing with a lot of
[ __ ] over here i gotta figure you need
someone to you need someone to clear out
the weed so you can see clearly and it
doesn't have tools it doesn't have to be
a catastrophic event in your life it
just could be something that you need
some help with big or small it doesn't
matter better help can help also it's
good if things are going well talk to
someone and talk about how well it's
going how great it is hey i feel
fortunate i have this going and that
it's it's fanta talk therapy can change
your life in such a positive way it's
fantastic so if you're thinking about
giving therapy a try better help is a
great option it's easy to get in the
pool it's convenient it's accessible
it's affordable it's entirely online you
get matched with the therapist after
filling out a brief survey and switch
therapist at any time and make it easy
peasy for you
uh
and here is the turkey whether you want
to be a better problem solver therapy
can help you get there visit
betterhelp.com garbage today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
garbage do it do it kip how about that
factor oh baby how about those factor
meals ready in about three minutes and
let me tell you something fall's coming
yeah summer's over gang things are gonna
start getting real hectic you wanna eat
right you don't wanna look a big fat pig
like me around christmas you wanna try
to keep it tight and i swear factor can
help with their delicious nutritious
meals that are ready in literally
minutes and then deliver them right to
your door my friend yeah guys it's
cheaper than takeout and that's a
serious win when it comes to saving a
couple bonies
uh factor is a perfect meal time
solution for on the go lifestyle fresh
never frozen meals are delivered ready
to heat and eat in two minutes so you
can fuel up fast and get on with your
day they now offer 30 plus meals per
week and 36 add-on options
uh like smoothies juices snacks and more
to keep you going add-ons uh depending
on how crazy your schedule is factor is
cheaper than take out seriously that's
in the book it's in the numbers that is
um
whether you get thing
when things get extra busy faster is
flexible you can change your order up
every week with plans from four to 18
meals per week sure or pause or
reschedule the deliveries i was doing it
for a long time before they were even
before they were even uh i know uh good
friend of our sponsor i love the factor
baby and we were traveling a lot
bada-bing bada-boom you hop in hey put
us on pause i'm changing this to four
weeks i need to i'll be home all week
70-18 let's get it going baby yeah it's
beach season get it tight what are we
doing uh not only do they offer fast
simple solutions when i need them the
most they help you stay on top of your
goals and it's hard when it's hard to
carve out time factor has endless
options however you eat choose from keto
calorie smart vegan veggie protein plus
the whole nine yards they take care of
you you know what i mean um factor has
everything i need uh for a week of good
eats here's the turkey baby head to
go.factor75.com
garbage130 and use code garbage130 to
get a hundred and thirty dollars yeah
across six boxes that's code garbage 130
at
go.factor75.com garbage130 for 130
off do it uh you got a swiffer at the
house at the apartment i think i do but
i don't it's one of the things i bought
that i don't think i've ever used do you
have a cleaning person just yeah but
they come rarely so the place is not i'm
never home so i'm like it doesn't get
that bad usually
like that that's very new york of you
yeah
where are you doing the laundry you're
doing it at the house are you dropping
it off i i do it you do it yeah really
it feels weird not to i feel like do
dropping it off somewhere is almost like
more work
huh i see what you're saying if it is if
there's not somewhere conveniently like
across the street or something yeah yeah
i do it myself but uh
yeah i people i tell people that and
they're weirded out by that sometimes
you strike me as a drop it off a fluff
and fold guy nah that's like the
quintessential new yeah new york movie
it's like unfolding i like to make a day
of it like i'll have a movie on and i'll
just be you know fully yeah yeah i like
it all right i've never hated anything
more than having to do laundry in my
apartment i don't know i like when
somebody else does it like when like
like like like my mom or somebody would
do it that makes it very close
it's the same exact process that he's
talking about like it's a movie on the
baskets are out it's being done he's
doing it i love it during like
basketball season might take a night off
i get a knicks game going i'm just
folding him yeah i like that you're
chilling all right that takes me forever
because i get mad during the game so
i've ripped three t-shirts
what kind of laundry detergent are you
using do you know what's the top of your
head or whatever the pods really is that
weird to use
yeah
more expensive i think oh that's true
then like a five gallon thing i like
pods rayo tuna subs
it's all right
my first new york apartment had a washer
and dryer in it you know
and i had no idea how good i had it
because i'm like yeah an apartment in
philadelphia
and then i everyone i was looking at
after that didn't happen did it was it
both in one or was it like on top
yeah it was a washer and it was next to
the it was next to the refrigerator it
went refrigerator washer dryer stove i
had that one apartment and it was all
the way up town and it was this was
uptown yeah it was a washer dryer in one
whoa and yeah so holy [ __ ] dude it would
take like 13 hours to drive
you think you're getting a good deal and
you're like it's just like shaking yeah
so it's like you press like you press
dry so it's like dude i swear to god it
would be shaking for like 11 hours
sometimes and my roommate would be like
dude can you not do laundry i got to
sleep tonight you know
holy [ __ ] how's the credit score sam
it's pretty good yeah yeah i don't
actually don't know but it's it's solid
um speaking of have you ever washed your
shoes in a washing machine
i think once yeah i did want because
they get stinky sometimes are you a
sneaker guy how many pairs of shoes
would you say you have a good amount but
i'm not like i'm not like i go into some
of these stores now and they're like
it's uh nike dunks for 480 sneakerheads
and you're like those were like 80 bucks
growing up i don't know why so i don't
i'm kind of like [ __ ] that no
i mean i like cool sneakers but i'm not
it's not where i want to spend my money
will you fart in an uber
that's a good one um
is it on the way to the airport into the
windows down then maybe okay because
there's a lot of air coming in okay why
airport because you're on a highway then
yeah you're on a highway you're going
quickly the wind is is there's like a
tunnel that's taken down
but if we're just farting a closed
window i think that's that's rude
because you're in a guy's car at the end
of the day so if it has one of those
plastic things oh and a cab yeah if it's
not if it's not making through
absolutely okay i mean also you have to
wait a taxi cab no question in a world
with no ratings i mean madness
madness will come over but if we're
talking an uber we could reflect poorly
on a score then you're like yeah i want
to behave yeah
i guess a cab is yeah a cab is the wild
west yeah you can get blown in a cab i
have
we were talking about derosa before
that's easy the the back of the cab
international waters yeah
yeah it's good i feel like a motel
um have you ever been kicked out of a
sporting event
no but we got someone kicked out
recently my brother and i because my
brother and i we it was literally
getting to the point was going to be a
fight
a guy dumped a beer in my brother's head
and my brother like pushed him and what
the [ __ ] is with that what the [ __ ] is
he drunk and we got in his face and i
was and i was like you [ __ ] idiot and
it was getting heated and i started
instagram storing the guy and there were
people in the section who followed me
and they were they started chanting
don't kick out sam don't kick out he's
got a special coming
and we and and the guy and the security
song like what's happening like this
piece of [ __ ] poured a beer my brother
and it got to where it was gonna be a
fight and i was like thank [ __ ] god
me and my brother and the toughest dudes
but it's a bad combo where we're like
willing we're ready to go i think we
could have taken these dudes but also
i'm like it's we're not leaving you're
just saying i'll get my ass kicked
i'm like if it comes to it i could take
a beating dude
[ __ ] me up it's like that episode of the
simpsons where homer just like lets
people get tired of the [ __ ] out of him
yeah dude uh yeah so the guy he got
tallest have i ever been tossed no i
have thank god no have you ever tried to
start the wave at a sporting event no
but i've gone with the wave i don't know
i gotta go with it if it comes in a
champion
[ __ ] you gotta go with the weight i
don't i don't love the wave i'll partake
if you have to but no never have you
guys been thrown out of a sporting event
now
no
i don't think so a lot of bars my
brother's friend got arrested at the vet
and went to the vet jail we were at a
phillies game yeah veteran stadium my
parents had to go get him out of here
wow yeah like the nero and silver
linings yeah hell yeah 100 yeah that's
uh that's the the sporting events like i
i for the same reason i don't behave
super badly i uh
i like that shit's gotten wild well yeah
i don't like that [ __ ] and also some
dude getting punched in front of his kid
the kid's bawling his eyes out i hate
that dude
i was drunk one time they gave me floor
seats from the knicks and i was
shit-faced
in the front row was like a pre-season
game that's where i get floor seats too
they're like no one else wants these you
can have that i fought lebron
king of the g-league it was nick's
wizards and john wall was like just off
like a one-year
injury or whatever and he gained a lot
of weight and i was shit-faced and my my
trolling was like you've gotten much
heavier john and he's looking at me he's
here and he's just like shaking his head
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm that guy put on a
couple of pounds
i was like john wall [ __ ] hates me
yeah and uh
yeah i was like that that was like ooh i
don't want to do that again that was but
i was hammered yeah it happens that's
free alcohol booze gets the best of you
something yeah i want to know was the
guy you and your brother were beefing
with was he a nick fan too i couldn't he
wasn't in any knicks gear and we were so
i mean that [ __ ] your security who are
you gonna side with true gotta support
the team there you go my brother was in
a ewing jersey from the 90s so will you
wear if you go if say you go to a nick
game but not not here if you go to an
away game will you wear your next jersey
i would yeah yeah yeah why not all right
i mean nick's one yankees is harder than
knicks because people i really hate it
everybody hates you everybody that's not
a yankees fan hates the ending the
knicks aren't winning enough for they're
not threatening they're like oh that's
cute i feel like wearing that that's
good i feel bad for people who show up
to eagles games wearing like a minnesota
vikings
it's dude it's just like what are you
doing
yeah it's gotten better than what it was
do they have any good teams i mean if
the twins are always threatening to
leave like a [ __ ] uh battered woman
they're always like we're gonna be gone
soon
yeah and then who else the tea wolves
the t-moves are kind of good now the the
minnesota wild had to run for a second
the hockey team oh that's right i think
they did all right
but i mean they're not a sports hub
is there baking soda in your fridge no
no
is that is that good or bad it's trashy
baking soda it depends i i i to me it's
trash definitely in the freezer what's
in the freezer by the way geez i got
some like frozen berries should we
butcher box meats
i'll go through like uh smoothie phases
i got a lava good smoothie phase and
like i'm turning it all around yeah and
it never lasts yeah so the hacker makes
fruit or whatever
but you can do a lot of stuff that that
frozen fruits all right if you put that
in a blender with some vanilla ice cream
that's not really the smoothie i'm just
saying
even acai you got an acai [ __ ]
milkshake they're not bad have you ever
looked at the nutritional facts from a
for an acai bowl they're not good
you think you're being healthy you're
like 78 grams of sugar in a bowl this
like how is that you might as well just
have haagen-dazs at that point it tastes
like meatballs are good throw a little
peanut butter and granola on there some
chocolate chips [ __ ] good night
you just described to sunday
they really it's brilliant what it is
you're eating dessert for breakfast but
i don't even think they're marketing as
healthy i think we just see it we go
this is a new word i learned recently
it's gotta be healthy that's a great
point no one's going this is the most
healthy thing we just look at it and we
we see that the tropical name we go
that's pretty good well it's like it's
like when subway had a run and they were
like we're [ __ ] healthy dude and
you're like we used to think subway was
healthy because they got us with the sun
chips the stuff the sun chips
they were trotting around
20 years dude i knew he wasn't gonna be
trusted when they told us that was real
avocado
i know they were keeping some [ __ ] from
us this is deeper than i thought it's
[ __ ] nerd's life that bread too is
like you know they got it with the yoga
mats yeah but i like a good toner to
tuna hoagie from subway they're all
right sometimes i'll do some downward
dog on my uh
italian
green
[Laughter]
ah you got a checkbook
not anymore i do but i don't know where
it is everything's uh everything's
digital electronic baby pretty good i
like that uh what was your high school
mascot a panther
that's all right it's normal is it yeah
yeah yeah it was all right you grew up
in the city yeah so this is a little bit
skewed in your favor but okay what was
the name of your chinese spot in your
pizza place growing up geez i mean there
wasn't a pizza place because it's new
york yeah it was just pizza but uh well
and the first one was chinese chinese
where did you go where were we places
was really good that's not there anymore
i love them trying to think what else uh
damn i mean
chinese was kind of similar and like
everyone says like new york is uh
like the best pizza like new yorkers i'm
like i never i never believe that i
think we're like 300 hitters i think
we're just like gonna get on base every
time there's more average pizza but
there's also a lot of bad pizzas they
started opening up all those places the
pizza and pasta the pizza and falafel
dude
it's a lot well new york but new york
you'll even a bad slice in new york is
better than most places but
new haven connecticut is where the best
pizza is shout out sally's yeah shout
out to them frank pepe's i mean they
they have all the spots but yeah
same with new york like la's got [ __ ]
good chinese i hate to give it to them
but they're changing really [ __ ] good
i hate to give la credit for anything
that's how new york is yeah but uh no
they have great chinese new york's got
good chinese but
sf is great chinese too yeah damn good
dim sum there
yeah we were just there we didn't get we
were there for like three hours oh i'm
gonna give you some i'm gonna give you
some spots chinese spot in new york
though god damn ain't nothing better
than that uh that's showing up i like
the ones that are like szechuan that are
like will give you like uh fish and a
chili sauce or something and yeah and
you know or they'll do like scrambled
eggs and shrimp they'll do like really
chinese dishes where you're like i
didn't even know this existed this is
like a weird but steve had it's just
like whoever likes it um
what's your go-to what's your favorite
pizza place in new york
oh that's slice spot i mean slice i go
to joe's because it's late night
i mean joe's in the west village is
where i just end up yeah craving pizza
especially last weekend yeah i like that
i like i mean john's for a pie
phenomenal john's on bleacher john's is
so good surely everything they do when
there's good tool all the italian food's
fantastic that's a classic i love i love
john's i love joe's um
joe's is great because
a lot of the places you see a long line
and you're like i'm [ __ ] but joe's
they they keep it moving
then you go to like bleeker street pizza
and it's like three people but it takes
you 40 [ __ ] minutes i hate i just
everything they go over the top with all
the different toppings and all that [ __ ]
the salad pizza this pizza to that pizza
it's wild you gotta keep it tight dude
joe's literally is like unless there's
400 people in line i'm like i'm gonna
wait because it just goes that quick
it's great yeah joe's pizza is is
consistent
they were slipping for a minute but i
think they're back on track it also
depends on what time you go a little bit
as well and how drunk you are that's the
thing they think you won't notice a
burned slice it's three a.m and yeah
maybe i won't but don't get cocky on it
yeah but you're gonna yeah
tell them to write home without either
yeah don't break my trust of course do
you have a bar at the house you have a
little bar area set up uh i don't have a
bar set up but i have like a closet full
of a shitload of booze okay i have a lot
of alcohol in there
yeah i have a lot i have like a lot of
whiskeys and a lot of uh problem is like
when you have a drinking podcast people
just start gifting you alcohol and i'm
like yeah i'm trying to like weed off so
like i i need some like health in my
life mm-hmm that's acai bowls yeah
that's the other thing people like well
you know they'll be like let me uh send
him a shot on stage i'm like do i have
to always be drunk now yeah yeah i'd
like to i'd like to be sober sometimes
but uh
yeah i got a lot of whiskey wine
some gin
you know mixers i'll do like a martini
or like if i'm making a drink at home
martini negroni manhattan you'll have a
cocktail
i'll make i'll make a good cocktail i
like oh man i was just at a
like a chain restaurant where they list
the nutritional facts in manhattan i was
like i had no idea that many calories
i'll pound like four or five of those
like that and then i'm just like wow
that's really unhealthy all right you
just ruined my week yeah thanks those
brandy cherries add up
i love those chips oh man i crushed
those things a dark i mean dude anything
that you're bringing from a sunday over
into the drinking world
that's a win i like all like
places that i worked at the the bar
fruit big fan little olives get a little
salty have an orange slice a couple of
cherries nothing wrong good olive yeah
getting martini drunk is is classic big
fan dirty martinis huge fish you can't
do that i can't do the martinis yeah i'm
just starting to stumble into the blue
cheese olives too i never really liked
them
it's like an appetizer with your drink
you ever go to a place and they're like
that's amazing the jalapeno olives are
great yeah and then you ever go to a
place where they sometimes they get a
little carried away with the bloody mary
you get like a like oh there's like a
burger
in there or something like what the [ __ ]
piece of shrimp bacon jesus christ this
with that stuff you know that stuff
isn't fresh though that's just sitting
in the cooler that was left over from
brunch yeah i don't care give me my
favorite butcher box oh what a bunch of
my favorite love that butcher box gang
you like top quality meat delivered
right to your door i got two words for
you butcher box get on it we're talking
grass fed grass finished beef we're
talking free-range chicken wild caught
seafood wild caught fresh pork delicious
no antibiotics no hormones delivered
right to your door uh-huh guys the the
good folks
no nay the great folks over there at
butcherbox.com have sent me have sent
out so much meat i got a comment on my
goddamn ears and my [ __ ] over here
i mean you think we're joking yeah it's
genuinely bonkers the amount of meat
they send us i love these goddamn people
i will support them till the dad die
we'll ride into the storm with the great
folks over there put your box and
support the people that support the show
yes uh guys you might be wondering like
how butcher box has these wild crazy
offers i wonder what it could be uh do
you like chicken cause if you do
open up buddy we got a tractor trailer
full of it for you guys it's time to
take chicken breast off your grocery
list butch i mean this is [ __ ] bonker
it should be called bonko's box because
butcher box is offering our listeners
the deal that they've never offered
before free chicken for a year yeah get
two pounds of free-range chicken organic
chicken breasts for free in every order
when you sign up at butcherbox.com ayg
use code ayg claim this deal at
butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg do it do
it um do you have a dive bar like a
go-to dive bar you like
i i feel like in the city i mean because
i don't have like that many bars i just
go to sure
drink after spots or whatever yeah i'll
have a drink at the celery usually or
like the olive tree or the uh
what do you call it the uh fat black pus
that's a good bar yeah the bar over
there is great trying to think like is
there a dive geez i mean there's a place
growing up i love called the subway and
i think they move locations but they
still exist it
like it was such a [ __ ] look
everyone in there looked like they just
got laid off
it was amazing everyone was just nursing
the saddest looking drink the booths had
like duct tape on them
they were everything was sticky you know
yeah you could tell like they just never
cleaned the bar never wiped the menu
down or anything yeah it was great i
remember uh i remember the bartender
just like grabbed my friend and planted
a big kiss on his mouth i was like this
is a [ __ ] dive yeah
yeah my friend was like what the [ __ ]
and i was like dude it's a dive you
gotta you gotta let him sexually assault
him
you two are legally married now just so
you know uh will you sleep with your
socks on
in the winter sometimes i'll do the like
the really heavy uh like the marine the
marina wool yeah if it gets too cold
what are you sleeping in normally i have
poor circulation just underwear usually
but i'll throw the socks i look
ridiculous wait a minute hold on in the
winter you're still sleeping in your
boxers yeah i have bad circulation so i
i uh you need them and then you're more
i'm doing the weighted blanket now dude
i have a [ __ ] up neck so i got a
tempurpedic pillow i lay on my back i
have the weighted blanket and i'm not
healthy so i do like the uh i do like
six cups of coffee a day i drink alcohol
i'll wake up with cramps in my leg in
the middle of the night and then i just
wake up under the blanket i look like
i'm an insane asylum i'm just waking up
like ah
it's brutal
i feel like you have headphones on when
you tell them no no no no no
i think she's just like that
any time you sunglasses you should never
need more than like two things to go to
sleep that's terrible oh i have a
sleeping mask on too i really like
sleeping well
will you rock that on the plane if
you're taking it if you're going snoozy
time of course who cares who cares how
silly you're looking to fly you're never
going to see these people again yeah i'm
with you on that hmm but i i will uh
yeah with the sleeping i will do do you
guys do socks when you sleep or not no
no if i if i have a mom when i go i take
them off that's like that gets me night
night time i'll i'll take them off with
my feet to me it's like the end of the
day it's like any all the stress is gone
like the you know the tightness of a
sock it's off interesting well you get a
baggy sock
[Laughter]
those socks are they're a little more
baggy sure sure
yeah i just don't get anything on my
toes um all right let's do a couple from
patreon this is from thick uh
uh what is the best day drinking holiday
geez that's a that's a great question
because i think the hack answers is
saint patties that's a terrible day
drinking holiday oh patty saint patty's
day
stinks it's a nightmare it sucks it's
amateur night i i always lean
for me this is going to sound weird from
a jew but i think christmas sure yeah
that's one of my favorite drinking days
when you were growing up did you do did
you guys do christmas or would you do
the jewish move the chinese food in the
movie that's that was our move so
jealous yeah really oh my gosh i would
think greg rogel used to have a bit
about it how jews on on you know on
christmas day we own this city yeah
it's all ours
but uh if i could get the presents and
still get a little chinese and see
and see a new movie in an empty theater
i'd be all right i love that yeah and
now it's just basketball all day so i'm
like oh i'm just ordering in chinese
food and watching eight hours of
basketball and getting drunk it's
amazing but uh that's a big one
i also say obviously thanksgiving is a
great day drinking holidays sure for
sure how about you guys
i would say i'll give you this and it's
because we do uh we start with the
manhattans kind of early as a family
like all my uncles and stuff and they're
always bringing new [ __ ]
you know new liquor or new chair i got
this chair it's whatever so it's like
everybody really brings their a game
then we just get [ __ ] sloshed off
[ __ ] manhattan's my uncle has the
best line he says two's not enough and
three's too many i was like that's
perfect that's great well that's the
thing about it's like uh like tits right
that's what they say about martinis they
say one it one's not enough
two is perfect three is too many four's
a party yeah that's very right
right i put down six the other night at
peasant
oh two weeks
we went out for my birthday day drinking
on christmas is awesome also because
like we talked about the weather but
like cold
i take cold day drinking over warm days
yeah i guess i
honorable mention thanksgiving but
christmas is worth the cake baby i'll
give it to you i like it fourth of july
you're all wrong
yes you're sweating no no you're
sweating usually you get screwed where
you you have to go back to work the next
day christmas you might have the next
day off or something like that i don't
know no fireworks on christmas where's
the danger
i need a thrill i like toby's passion
right yeah i mean i i hear you on that i
think this year i was
coming back from a road gig that day so
i think it already went to like the back
of my mind yeah but it probably is it's
a good family it is a good drinking day
i agree
i'm not a big saint paddy's guy i'm not
a big new year's eve guy either new
year's eve is horrible amateur night
it's amateur and it's like the
expectation of it as well of like dude
you're gonna go here you gotta get a
ticket you gotta do it it's like get the
[ __ ] out of here it's also the sadness
if you're alone where like there's that
countdown you're like [ __ ] i'm alone you
know i think new year's eve is just sad
in general because like that year's over
it's the beginning of the year it's
[ __ ] january and [ __ ] it's dark
out it's cold it sucks it stinks
yeah no it's it's a terrible terrible
night and then you have those people who
post those tone deaf posts like things
they accomplish this year and you're
like apparently not self uh awareness
yeah this is how great i am yeah you
[ __ ] idiot
uh 2023 is going to be my year
um you hope that guy gets run over by a
bus january 1st right before midnight
yeah you only made it to 1159 huh big
shot
uh this one's from tj have you ever had
an overweight bag at the airport and had
to take loose clothes out of your
luggage in front of everybody yeah oh
you know even worse you know what
happened to me once at an airport i was
doing a long trip so i had i had a cheap
ass like
fifty dollar maybe uh chip rolly bag
they never last that's it's got i
deserve this one thing spring for
luggage even if you're right you're
gonna lose a wheel the handle's going to
break something you could miss a flight
i mean what happened was i oh it just
for some reason it just comes undone as
i'm going down escalators i'm like [ __ ]
there's clothes a toothbrush
a toothbrush
i just watch on the escalator i'm like
that's just a gross site that's a wrap
so i had to just carry everything and i
go to a luggage store and it's like 6
a.m they're like we're not open yet i'm
like come on
grab all this [ __ ] to another luggage
store and they go oh this will work and
i'm like all right cool and then i look
at the price tag it's like 550 dollars
and i'm like oh look they're like it is
a cool bag
and i still use it's a great bag but
holy [ __ ] they had me they have they
have you hostage you got to do it oh
yeah but you see what you see where that
money goes you're like this is a damn
fine piece of luggage i know i i sprung
for my first nice uh carry like roller
bag and it's like a [ __ ] game changer
from i used to use that duffel
i like people it's tough especially when
you're traveling as much as we do now
it's like yeah you're just gonna jerk
your neck out i know yeah and also the
you notice the bat the cheap rolly bags
you're like jerking it i'm like [ __ ]
like a grocery store card yeah yeah
the wheels are wobbly
and then you do the uh you do the actual
one you're like i'm gliding this dude
when you if you have one which like oh
most of the good ones are
push like vert like you don't have to
toe it you know what i mean it just roll
it just cooks right next to you what are
you talking about like a tumi atomy i
got a nice herschel that i like i was
walking recently and some guy goes
that's nice luggage to his buddy and
pointed at me really like a million
bucks he hit his buddy
holy could tell me [ __ ] the rest of the
day that's a nice feeling yeah that's
good i've never gotten that
dude i remember yours recently we were
coming home from texas yeah and he's
duct taping it i dropped it with a lint
roller he was a little bit
genius he took the lint roller and used
it as tape
to tape his luggage oh my god but then
the handle wouldn't go down so he
couldn't get it it was just a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
whenever it's like a designer or
something that's not known for luggage
you i had like a kenneth cole i'm like
that's not what he's known for
jackets
it's like you see a guy with one of
those bags and you're like puma what the
[ __ ] yeah i saw somebody go to
charleston that had an adidas roll-on
not their specialty
remember when they tried to pimp out
cologne and stuff like that too
everybody
[Music]
you smell like a gambling problem
smells like the over
[Laughter]
jordan put his name on everything he had
the steak house he had oh yeah michael
jordan's steakhouse still open
oh it's open i stayed in a hotel right
next to it and i i almost went there as
a goof and and then i text somebody's
like dude it's the worst place you've
ever been and it's insanely expensive
i'm so glad we didn't go who did you say
you texted
uh a guy from chicago james webb who
directed my special but uh you know uh i
was like dude should we should gary and
i go and he goes don't go there dude
trust me so i thought you texted jordan
you're like i texted him and i'm like he
said don't go like what the [ __ ] you're
just dropping this [ __ ] on me now i was
like yo jump man what's happening
huh
we text like crazy
finish it off with a three-pointer
sunday
it looks [ __ ] horrible that place but
chicago's got such good food you know
the flu game special is that possible
um somebody some i forget who some
athlete has one around the corner from
here
i forget who it is dude they used to
have some real trash
or something oh yeah walt frazier fraser
yeah oh yeah new york royalty that guy
is the coolest he's my one of my
favorite athletes of all you see i
interviewed him once for when i had a
sports show on msg and he's the nicest
guy and i could tell he was like oh i
have to get interviews i'm like i'm
gonna ask him really good questions so
he's really pumped and i was doing stuff
like you guys used to be roommates in
hotels on the road you know and he was
shocked i knew that i was like you and
phil jackson were roommates and he's
like yeah he was like we had this great
conversation and then they poked me
they're like ask him like about his
interviewing and like how he uh
commentates games and i was like how do
you like commentating games and he was
like it's all right and that's all they
used
i had this like amazing moment with him
like that'll work that's fine
i felt meaningful connection just down
the toilet
he's the man though i mean he's a he's a
new york legend
uh i had my birthday there one year
my family my family was like this is not
good food
yeah i mean
he's not again that's like you know
getting puma luggage he's known for
duncan
i'm not the rib eye my mom was like this
is not good
i could picture your parents very
refined manhattan nights yes yeah
absolutely my mom especially very proper
like hates my humor like it's and it
doesn't hate it but i'm like when you
got haircut when you have a mom behaving
like that like
that's where your humor comes that's
where it comes from because
her being like sam and i'd be like
that's a joke that's a reaction right
there so she would get upset and i'm
like well that's the joke and uh man i'd
see her face in the crowd sometimes like
she'll come support the show but i can
tell that she hates a lot of the jokes
so she's like in the crowd and i just
see i'm in the middle of a set i see her
in the crowd like
what the [ __ ] that's not helping mom
just don't come
no she's she's not going to derek jeters
with me afterwards i can tell you that
kiss that gift bag goodbye
no she's like she's supportive but
there's certain jokes that like they you
know bothers her sure sure sure
uh this is from ben is a garbage to
share custody of a pet with an ex
it's not garbage it's insane that's why
i don't know why you would you gotta go
[ __ ] band-aid right off separated
what is this kramer vs kramer give her
the [ __ ] cat dude
let it go
share custody so what like you get the
dogs on the weekends i don't know
doesn't make sense to me that is also
how do you explain that to your next
partner yeah oh we got i love this dog i
have to give it back to sheila on monday
so get your cuddles in today whose room
is this i mean this is this is a
terrible i had a friend had this
recently
and uh his girl asked for their cat back
and i said
no and he said why i was like she broke
up with you yeah you get the cat and he
said yeah i respect that yeah he would
have been a backbone and then i think he
gave her the cash
you don't want to be in this family
anymore yeah you know what i mean so
you're not getting the
taking a cat what are you nuts she's
meryl streep you're dustin hoffman you
stepped up dude yeah no i agree with
that [ __ ] that yeah but also at the same
time put the cat through college do all
that stuff huh i i think i got here
that's madness
yeah i i could never do it but also also
this is like the people that
invest in a pet too early in the
relationship sometimes oh yeah and
you're like three months in maybe don't
get a cat yeah don't don't commit 18
years to something whatever my ex and i
thought about we all thought about it
during cove and we're like we're home
all day let's get a little cat perfect
and then you're like no because then
you're they're gonna they're gonna get a
vaccine at some point we're gonna get
out of this goddamn apartment yeah
but we all thought about it during covet
the you know a lot of people did a lot
of people gave them back that's [ __ ]
up that's real [ __ ] that's evil
you gave it you gave it a taste of the
good life yeah see all the things see
how things could be
now back to the [ __ ] shelter two
weeks in a relationship you get a sea
turtle together what the [ __ ] was 150
years
those people get the points how about
the people that have pet birds
that's big
no no it's big on the show especially
loose birds if you have loose birds in
the house which we have had a good
amount of guests that have had loose
birds guys walking through like
washington square park with like a
toucan on their shoulder
i used to i used to tutor a kid and they
were just birds flying everywhere i'm
like
i have add already you think i can
[ __ ] focus if i'm like just looking
this the [ __ ] word also there's a
barber shop by me and i go there and
they have birds and i'm what
i don't like i have a choice to do that
i [ __ ] hate that yeah it is my
favorite they're just in there flying
around no they're in the cage but it
still bugs me i don't know i don't like
it our neighbor has birds we hear them
all the time an annoying pet yeah an
annoying pet i love birds but keeping
them and having them flying around the
house
no unless you rehabilitate them
obviously dude i was just in a park and
there was like a proper i don't even
know what it was a parakeet like a
domestic bird just chilling on a tree
and i was like that's somebody's [ __ ]
yeah they just let it go
and like you can see the pixar movie
right there
you could tell it was domesticated
because we walked up to when it just
[ __ ]
did like for me like for me to the
[ __ ] cup a foot away just sat there
staring at us i'm like this is singing
this excuse me to [ __ ] out
that doesn't sound like a movie right
there the domesticated bird
um hi this one's from robert uh
ten dollar homie here like a gentleman
is the garbage have is it garbage to
have to borrow gym clothes for gym class
in middle or high school
garbage
i don't know
yeah i've gone to the bin before lost
and found that yeah off it's tough it's
gross someone else's gym shorts the lost
and found in gym class is different than
the regular that is a [ __ ] bucket of
sweat and [ __ ] dirt underwear
disgusting yeah it's garbage we used to
i don't know it's not your your proudest
moment if you have to do it you guys
might be too young for this but uh
umbros were big when i was a kid shout
out to the umbrella and you could steal
those out of lockers real easy because
they were so thin pull through the grate
oh yeah you're about if you got hemmed
up
yank one of those out dude those little
grates holy [ __ ] oh yeah damn a [ __ ]
hanger in there fresh pair of humvees
good night
gym class was the [ __ ] who's doing
shorts heists
i'm not wearing jeans to play kickball
like a loser we would get trying to win
the game here we would get in trouble if
we did like you would get like oh yeah
you would get in trouble you know you
would drop whatever percent like five
percent or make you start running in
[ __ ] dress shoes or something like
that get the [ __ ] out of here with that
yeah now i'm stealing
what's you know it's me or him bush
comes to shove
i don't know what i've had a couple of
umbros taken two it's like umbrellas at
the front of a diner you take them and
you leave them yeah that bin is a risk
i i yeah you can't you can't leave them
in the bin no put them under the table
it's like when people put the jacket on
the hook i'm like you're going to lose a
jacket oh i've lost so in a bar or
whatever i lost so many jackets that way
leaving it somewhere or whatever
somebody else or someone else just takes
it i don't even think
another you're just filled you're there
at a bar full of drunk people who are
like oh this black pico this one's mine
yeah that's the least that they've done
that night of course yeah i probably
groped a woman at the bar he's gonna
take your umbrella i had another comic
at a club one time do that they took my
i had a black jean jacket they took mine
who was it did he was like 120 pounds
i'm like you didn't realize it wasn't
bruce bruce
it's the only other comic that could do
it earthquake sold my hoodie
earthquake's actually in shape i know um
but he sounds like he shouldn't be i
know he's got a great special that's
that's special you shouldn't be a thin
comic named earthquake or normal he was
bigger back in the day which is the
earthquake i was referring to okay all
right fair enough [ __ ] fact checker
frank over here take it easy anyway i
was gonna go with earthquake and then i
realized he was smaller and i went with
bruce bruce i picked the low fruit
um yeah this kid was like 120 like you
didn't realize that you were wearing a
5x yeah halfway up the [ __ ] door
wild yeah do you really how big
the jean jack the jean jacket in
question was a 5x are you serious yeah
i'm down to four now it's a 4x t-shirt
that's good yeah we're getting there 4x
yeah that's [ __ ] huge
i like how he's like oh that's good
jesus is huge but it's weird when i look
at like a 2x i'm like god that looks so
small
it's crazy yeah well what size is that
is that an extra large or a large that's
a large man i couldn't get my toes in
there
all right uh this let's do a couple more
here this one's from leon uh first time
long time have you ever been on the
receiving end of a t-shirt cannon at a
sporting event yeah really yeah i caught
one once yeah really yeah yeah was it
that yankee shirt sure
it was a it was a yankee shirt has a
chase logo right now
[Applause]
oh cool an american airlines met shirt
uh just what i always wanted but uh yeah
i caught a shirt once it's like a shitty
shirt you know it's like but i have it
still it's a nick shirt you know have
you ever been on the jumbotron
no i oh wait have i
and have you made it on the jumbotron
when you were on the where no
no as a celebrity i was with michelle
wolf who was on at once and she and she
i was next to her on it but no i've
never i've never
it would i'm glad they haven't it would
be the saddest response yeah it'd be
it'd be
how many thousand people just like huh
yeah
i'll be in next gear so at least be like
all right he's a knicks fan but they'd
be like but we don't yeah one guy at the
top of the city i'm like oh no [ __ ]
[Applause]
if they don't if they don't know me in
the next game they don't [ __ ] know me
that's that's right
that's like where you're like oh [ __ ] i
just got humbled i think it happened to
krista stefano when they put him on yeah
i think once or twice after uh phil
collins and phil collins won what yeah
and phil collins was like it's okay mate
and he's like yeah no it's no one cheers
yeah they're like shout out to chrissy
dude the roof came down for phil yeah
they cut to him and they were like oh
we're making chrissy d follow the guy
who did cesudio
this guy was in genesis what are we
doing here but christie is a new york
guy christie's the new york uh new york
royal family shout out to chrissy d
um what about home run foul balls you
ever shag one of those i've never gotten
one although i was at a game once and it
went off a thing and hit my friend in
the head
and he had to go to the hospital and i
was like i gotta leave a [ __ ] yankees
game
mike michael lowell uh hit it when he
played for the yankees briefly remember
mike lowell that's all right now did
they do anything for him i don't
remember i was like [ __ ] pissed i was
like maybe miss the yankees game you
usually get a bat or something out of
that
really the hell yeah
damn yeah you get a little something
something
let me ask you this yeah as an adult as
a kid as different as an adult have you
ever brought your glove to the game
not as an adult it's just two it's
ridiculous maybe if i had like a son at
the game with me it would be like a
father-son thing 100 but like but yeah
isn't it you and vader can't roll up to
us
to a giants game and look like
make-a-wish kids
no we uh no gary no i would never uh do
that as an adult and also you're just
like an adult with a glove you look
ridiculous yeah it's a tough look yeah
that would mentally although but then
you see the right thing a ball does come
at you though and you don't you're like
i wish i had a glove yeah you gotta go
bare-handed you gotta take it i know you
gotta take it though you're going to get
a delete at the best case you get a
jammed thumb maybe worse yeah you got to
use the hat sometimes you can see people
use the hat and you're like pretty slick
i've seen dudes holding babies
there's one just went viral dude just
[ __ ] calmed it like that was it kind
of wasn't even looking up just like he
just holds up the wrong hand the baby
gets hit he's like [ __ ]
hey get a free bat
kid took over the team uh all right do
you know do you or anyone you know have
a third nipple which i didn't realize we
already talked about three nipples uh no
not that i know any anybody who kids
grew up with had weird anything not that
i i don't know about the third nipple
that's like uh did you guys know a third
nipple guy we had a theoretically i do
you have a third nipple theoretically
yeah there's a split in the middle is
the boob as big as the other two
[Laughter]
theoretically i have three nipples wait
your nipples split it's split down the
middle yeah it's like an injury or
you're a born that way i got it got
sliced if you're a woman you'd have to
do a 3xl bra
[Laughter]
triple cups that's crazy that you uh you
have a third nipple is that
theoretically i mean if your cat it's
one nipple you were born with one nip i
was born with one but it's like a
salamander when like two tails will grow
right enough
the clinical term for it is accessory
nipples which is ah like it's a process
like it's a civic and you put rims on it
accessory oh my god that's tough um
all right let's see let's do one more
here and then we can wrap her up um
this is from molp anyone you know
referred to as going to bed as hitting
the sack or any other idiom for that
matter i feel like a lot of parents
typically have hidden a sack
i've said it yes getting a sack we had
grown up was my dad would say up the
wooden hill to go up the wooden hill i
don't know i've never heard it sound
amish the shower we called the rain
locker what yeah i'm getting in the ring
get up there and get in the rain locker
somebody that sounds like where you sit
after you got molested
i gotta go with the rain locks
off in the rain locker that's uh tell
uncle charles or sorry watch the shame
off me in the rainbow a lot of crying in
the rain i would say uh hit the sack
yeah you know get some get some sleep i
don't like when people like get some z's
and like catch them z's is tough that's
tough that's like when people say lol in
real life like dude that's not just text
that if you need to but right
do you have any uh i'm sorry no no go
ahead do you have anything you like
saying for money that's a big one we say
like bucks or do you have like fajoules
or anything you do dell dozens cash cash
money
get paid a couple of bones yeah yeah
bones is fun bones is an old-school one
bones is all right i like when we're out
yeah i would say cheddar and [ __ ] back
and like cheddar's great cheddar
is good too some glop or like anything
that you like it can just be money yeah
because you're like everyone likes
cheddar we've been saying turkey a lot
in the turkey turkey
yeah turkey now let's get to the turkey
turkey's the most underrated meat
because really
you're opening up a whole candidate yeah
what are you talking about here's why
it's a turkey sandwich always good i
love that i'll give you that turkey
lunch meat you're talking about i love
sliced turkey of course but because
actual turkey no
turkey on the sandwich is very nice no
no i agree that's what i'm saying i'm
not talking about actual like
thanksgiving turkey i would rather do
chinese on [ __ ] things
like
a couple of stiff drinks yeah but uh no
but actually just sliced turkey because
like i love pastrami but you feel like
[ __ ] after you eat that
i can feel the nitrates [ __ ] coming
out of my turkey you never feel that bad
i almost feel good you almost feel good
light that's why it's a good sandwich a
little cheddar avocado mayo that's a
good sandwich it's like a protein shake
throw some vanilla ice cream on there
wonderful ladies and gentlemen mr
samurail brand new netflix special out
right now
time tomorrow do yourselves a favor and
check it out like we said in the
beginning we mean this a true standard
comedian a true headliner a true new
yorker sammy thank you so much thank you
guys anything else you want the folks
out there to know plug dates or whatever
uh when does this come out uh
two days yeah dania beach florida this
weekend louisville a really expensive
round trip ticket so you might want to
make it
irvine
omaha phoenix samurail.com shows
lexington kentucky i'm all over kids
working yeah games with names we might
be drunk
uh other specials on youtube and
uh whiskey i'm shocking a ton of [ __ ]
here love it baby kids working uh yeah
life is good man it's good to be working
thank you buddy congratulations we love
you kippy what do you got for me uh guys
we're
uh our second show we added in philly is
almost sold out so get those tickets if
they're not already gone by the time
this is out uh we're gonna be adding a
second show in boston and rhode island i
believe as those are [ __ ] sold out
um next week we'll be in springfield st
louis kansas city yeah coming through
missouri so get those tickets
springfield blue room yes oh nice
which i think could use some help so get
some
[Laughter]
gang we love you we'll see you next week
peace